لم يعرف مصيرها بعد هل هي في عداد الاموات
ام كتب لها عمر جديد لكن مذكراتها تركت
بصمه في قلوب من قراها مذكرات ساره نجت من
تحت انقاض مبنى بمدينه جندريس شمال حلب
وبعبارات مختلطه بين الحزن والامل
واسترجاع الماضي سطرت ساره مشاعرها
بعباراتها متالمه واضحك وماتت رغبتي في كل
شيء
ويعكس دفتر مذكرات ساره حجم الماساه التي
يعيشها السوريون منذ اندلاع الحرب ومدى
تاثرها او مدى تاثيرها على الاطفال
والجروح التي تتركها على نفسيتهم
ماساه سار التي لخصتها اصدر دفترها اعاد
الذكرياتها لما قبل الحرب وتحدثت فيها عن
فرحه العيد المسلوبه وذكريات افتقدتها
لاهلها واصدقائها
كلمات مذكرات الطفل السوريه تركت اثرا
كبيرا على مواقع التواصل وفي قلب رجل
الانقاذ الذي عبر عن حزن وحرقه بعد قراءته
لهذه المذكره
[موسيقى]